800 million dollars in urgent
humanitarian assistance 805 million
dollars for drug detection technology to
help secure our ports of entry
an additional 2,750 border agents and
law enforcement professionals to
physically secure our border the plan
includes 5.7 billion dollars for a
strategic deployment of physical
barriers or a wall the president Trump
promised that he would have a major
announcement today and there were some
details about it leaked beforehand and
that was that he was going to provide
two three years of protection for daca
recipients here in the United States now
that is what he mentioned in his speech
he's still asking for that five point
seven billion dollars in border wall
funding however his language on that was
a little bit different this time around
he mentioned that he wasn't looking for
a wall to cover the entire southern
border however he doesn't want
structures in certain areas and he's
asking for more in terms of border
security in a lot of different areas now
House Speaker Nancy Pelosi has already
responded she released a statement and
said that she does not accept what Trump
called a common-sense compromise
unfortunately his proposal is a
compilation of several previously
rejected initiatives each of which isn't
acceptable and in total do not represent
a good-faith effort to restore certainty
to people's lives it is unlikely that
anyone of this provision saloon would
pass the House and taken together there
non-starter so it looks like in the next
week we could see some legislation
presented by Trump and the Republicans
and we could also see some legislation
presented by Pelosi and the Democrats
however it remains to be seen exactly
how they're going to come together or if
that is going to happen